matter of survival for the dutch
if it weren't for the 22 000 kilometers
of dykes a large part of this land would
not even exist
but increasingly the country's defense
against the elements has to be
strengthened against rising sea levels
and storms
cardiovan low house has lived on the
water for decades and after documenting
the effects of climate change
in his own country and around the world
he says too much time is lost
it is quite possible that that if
nothing happens
that the netherlands could face three
meters sea level rise by the end of the
century which is in
80 years which is one generation so
and that would be catastrophic it would
mean that that maybe cities like
amsterdam rotterdam the hague would
would not exist anymore and have to be
relocated
the dangers not only come from the sea
but also from the rivers
that are swallowing more rainwater than
before storms like these are
increasingly common
over the dutch lowlands these strong
winds and high waves are threatening the
country's dikes
that were built hundreds of years ago
only up until here
and now have to be meters higher a race
against time as the climate is changing
more rapidly
than predicted
[Music]
in 1953 thousands died in the south of
the netherlands during flots
after the disaster large dams sluices
and storm surge barriers were
constructed
the massland carrying four times heavier
than the eiffel tower in paris
was built to protect the city of
rotterdam adaptation is culture in the
netherlands
we live with water already for thousands
and thousands of years
as the world's only special envoy for
water affairs
hank oving is stars to take the dutch
water expertise to the rest of the world
the world has to acknowledge that too
you don't
work with these challenges by looking
back
and recover after disasters no
adaptation is about looking ahead to the
future
and prepare yourself instead of working
against the water the dutch are
increasingly using its power to
strengthen the coastline
this so-called sand engine is a natural
way of creating a peninsula
by using sand and currents a method that
is now also being used along the coast
of the uk
but despite these innovations kadir is
less optimistic the netherlands can be
saved in the long run
well it's it's predicted that when honda
are in two are not 300 years that most
of the netherlands will not exist
anymore
even so the netherlands a third of which
is below sea level
is already beating the odds and its
centuries of knowledge of water
management
is seen as a key to its survival
prime minister has called this a day of
action
but action can only be taken if the
world works together and that is going
to be the main challenge here during
this summit because what we've seen
during the
covet 19 pandemic is that countries have
been
looking inward and been trying to help
their own economy so the big
question is are they can they put their
strength together
and make this work as a collective step
thanks very much steph vassen there
in the hague well